the CEO of Starbucks says he wants to
apologize personally to two black men
after video of their arrest in a
Philadelphia coffee shop spurred outrage
police say a Starbucks manager called
911 refused to leave after trying to use
the store's restroom without making a
purchase they were arrested for alleged
trespassing protesters have been
gathering at the Philadelphia store and
that's where Michelle Miller is this
morning she spoke with a men's attorney
in an interview you'll see first on CBS
this morning
Michelle good morning good morning the
two men say they simply came here for a
business meeting and we're waiting for
someone in as you can see for the second
straight day protesters have packed
inside this Starbucks to support them
they agree that this was a clear case of
racial profiling cell phone video shows
the two black business associates
staying calm in their seats as officers
repeatedly ordered them to lead a third
man their potential business partner
arrives a few minutes later in office to
move their meeting somewhere else but by
then it was too late when I walk in and
I don't know what or anything and I'm
dressed like this no managers calling
the police on me
attorney Stuart Cohen represents the two
men if they were white would this have
happened none of the white customers
were asked to leave and they were there
a lot longer than those young men who
were there just for a few minutes
activists accused both Starbucks and
Philadelphia police of racism
[Applause]
in a statement CEO Kevin Johnson called
the arrest quote reprehensible our store
manager never intended for these men to
be arrested and this should never have
escalated as it did he said these
officers did absolutely nothing wrong
police commissioner Richard Ross said a
Starbucks employee called 9-1-1 because
the men refused to leave after trying to
use the store's bathroom without
ordering anything first it is important
to emphasize an underscore these
officers had legal standing to make this
arrest author Melissa - Pino tweeted out
one of the videos because she was upset
by how the men were treated people who I
know in my everyday life have said
things like I can't believe that really
happens I want people to listen to
people who experience it and to
understand that it's real now these two
men were released after they the
Starbucks did not pursue any charges in
this case but their attorney says they
were fingerprinted they were arrested
and now these two men who had no for a
previous history in the criminal justice
system are now part of it the attorney
says they're willing to meet face to
face with Starbucks CEO Kevin Johnson in
the meantime Philly's mayor says he is
asked the city's Human Relations
Commission to investigate Norah Michelle
thank you so disturbing to watch that
happen can I don't sit in the mayor have
some quick work they need to get need to
start yeah I hope they do mean they do
mean